[Music]
this tender moment between North Korea
and leader Kim Jong-un and his daughters
stole the spotlight of a military parade
in Pyongyang as the country showed off
weapons it says are capable of hitting
the U.S mainland
and this was the fifth time since
November that the public has seen Kim
Joy believed to be the leader's second
child she's been seen holding hands with
her father and being surrounded by
senior military officials and her
appearances have raised questions about
why she's in the public eye now and
whether she could become the next leader
we take a look at how Kim jue is
presented in North Korean propaganda and
her significance to the regime
so Kim Joy first appeared at an ICBM
launch in November Kim Jay appeared with
her father holding hands and basically
surprising the world because we had
never seen one of the Kim children
before
since then she has appeared at multiple
military events instead of appearing
like they are spending loads and loads
of money on military equipment and
missiles bringing the daughter to these
events helps portray Kim Jong-un as a
father who is trying to protect the
nation with the weapons that they
possess
since North Korea first revealed that
they had their Nationwide outbreak North
Korea is struggling economically and
there have been restrictions to trade
despite all of that we had a record
number of missile launches in 2022.
analysts say that they need domestic
support for many of the missile launches
that they're doing
she is a symbol of the Next Generation
that the regime has to protect with the
weapons that they have
[Music]
so bringing Kim joy to these military
events it not only helps soften the
image of the military it also portrays
Kim Jong-un as a loving father Kim
Jong-un does want to appeal to the
public as a more generous and a more
caring figure
ever since Kim Joy appeared in public
there has been a lot of talk about
succession plans in North Korea so it's
very significant to see how senior North
Korean officials will shake her hand bow
to her be very respectful towards her
despite her being a 9 to 10 year old
child
but on the other hand some analysts say
that it might not be likely that a
female becomes the leader of North Korea
with North Korean leaders there are
these signs of portraying them as being
very different from Ordinary People and
for now the way we've seen State media
portray Kim Jai has been as a child as a
daughter as someone who Kim Jong-un is
trying to protect Kim Jong-un is only 39
years old and analysts say that it's
still too early for him to name a
successor both his father and his
grandfather ruled until their deaths and
it's likely that Kim Jong-un is going to
do the same